people of the internet's retirement tour
here and it is time to take a look at
the Hufflepuff common room a deep dive
based on the latest Hogwarts Legacy
trailer which showed us all of the
common rooms in great incredible detail
they all have so many fun secrets and
we're gonna break down the Hufflepuff
common room right now so after the first
time we ever saw the common rooms
Hufflepuff was Far and Away my favorite
I thought it was the most unique I
thought it was the most cozy so here in
this very first scene and one of the
things that I always like to talk about
in the first shot of the common rooms is
just the color palette the color that
jumps out to you most and with this one
it just feels very earthy there's lots
of Browns there's some yellows there's
some greens with all the plants around
they do have the stone floor but also
brick here above the fireplace we also
have a portrait here of Helga Hufflepuff
herself holding what looks to be the cup
not sure if it's the cup that eventually
becomes the horcrux for Voldemort but
it's interesting nonetheless also a nice
little Kettle here sitting above the
fire and then above the fireplace we
have what appears to be some Badgers
carved into the wood almost like they're
tumbling it appears to be different
stages of a badger I don't know doing a
flip down a hill just having a good time
it seems like to me honestly it's kind
of crazy how much there is in just this
first shot alone you also have some
books over here so ravenclaws not the
only one who have books around and to me
the most striking thing about the
Hufflepuff common room especially in
comparison to the others has to be the
plants there are just so many plants
throughout the common room the green
just really pops with the dark brown the
light brown that you have throughout the
rest of the common room like the
Gryffindor common room it definitely
seems like the hufflepuffs focus on
Comfort when it comes to the seating
although a lot of the seats look more
worn I mean look at this kind of light
brown couch here just looks like a very
worn out couch to me same thing for
these chairs over here on the right we
also have yet another notice board and
that chudley Cannon's poster yet again
even though we're kind of far away from
it at this point also have another
grandfather clock here and it's
interesting to see the similarities some
of the same item items even that appear
in multiple common rooms and then in the
next scene here we're actually going to
stay in the same room but the camera
moves a little bit so now we're on the
opposite side of the room which means
over here on the right we're going to
get a better look at the portraits here
and so far it seems like Hufflepuff is
kind of somewhere in between Ravenclaw
and Gryffindor when it comes to the
portraits not quite as many as
Gryffindor but more than Ravenclaw we
also get another look at the watering
can here which we saw in one of the
Hogwarts Legacy ASMR videos just one of
those fun little things that shows we
are in a magical world this isn't a
normal world we have this little magical
watering can that has just been
Bewitched to always do its job even in
the rain as we saw on the ASMR video
then I really like this Arch over here
on the left side and if you look there
underneath you see what a lot of people
are calling The Hobbit holes it's true I
definitely think Hufflepuff has taken
inspiration from Lord of the Rings and
from The Hobbit holes and it makes
perfect sense it really does fellow
Hogwarts Legacy content creator expecto
go who is a huffle puff I might add I
gotta give him credit for pointing this
out I think he's spot on with the fact
that the Hufflepuff common room and
these little holes here it kind of feels
like a burrow which makes total sense
for a badger for Hufflepuff I mean it
feels like we're deep within the Earth
here and all these little Burrows where
people are hanging out but we still have
Greenery we still have lots of life
growing here then we shift into another
scene here and on this one we can see
two different levels with an even better
look at those Burrows we have one two
three doors here on the bottom and then
three matching doors on the top and I'm
so curious where all of these lead is
one floor of the boys one floor of the
girls and then maybe they are further
split up by age I mean just because
those doors it really makes this common
room feel like it's going to be huge we
have another Wizards chess set here down
in the left and on the right side yet
another one of those large chests that
we have seen a number of times now in
the other common rooms looks like this
one also has a large cauldron just to
the left of it and more plants just like
the ravenclaws have books everywhere the
hufflepuffs have plan chance everywhere
as cozy as this common room is guys I am
highly highly allergic to a lot of
things out there so I don't know if I
would make it in the Hufflepuff common
room but all the greenery absolutely
helps to give it that warm feeling and
then we're gonna shift the camera view
here and we're gonna be in the upstairs
area now and if you've seen my Ravenclaw
video you know I talked about the
ravenclaws having these little study
Nooks well the hufflepuffs have
something similar here but it almost
seems like it's focused on relaxation
maybe we should call these relaxation
Nooks here because you just have these
pillows and then kind of this nice soft
cushion there seems like a nice spot to
grab a quick nap or to lie down and read
a book and then here in this upstairs
view we get a better look at the round
doors and also this stained glass that
is on either side of them and if you
take a look at all the detail both in
the stained glass and on the wooden door
and even here on the left on this wooden
railing and Archway they all sort of
resemble these little Vines which makes
me think of growth makes me think of
life that is honestly what the
hufflepuffs are all about loving life
loving people people and having a good
time now we know the Hufflepuff common
room is very close to the kitchens and
if you pause this one right when it
transitions over to the next scene take
a look over here on the left side and I
think this here is actually the doorway
to the Hogwarts kitchens so we learn
about the layout of this in Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire and we know that
the kitchen was located directly
underneath the Great Hall down a
staircase that leads toward the
Hufflepuff basement they are also
underground we talked about that already
with the feeling of the Burrows So
reading from the HP Wiki here downstairs
in a broad stone basement Corridor
brightly lit and decorated with food
themed paintings one could tickle a pair
on a painting of a bowl of fruit and
it's a little hard to see what fruits we
have here but I think we definitely do
have a pair and so my guess is that this
is the door to the Hogwarts kitchens now
we'll have to see just how close they go
to the book here because in the book
when you tickle the pair it would turn
into a large green door handle can't
wait to see if they actually take it
that far because this whole area here
looks I mean exactly how I pictured it
in my mind and pretty accurate to how
it's described in the books now if you
remember just outside the Slytherin
common room we had the Torches with the
snakes on either side and we have
something similar here another large
torch with the badger surrounding it the
corridor was also described as having
lots of paintings with most of them
having to do with food and that is
exactly what we see here on the right
side and here on the left side as well
once they turn the corner we see two
more of the large columns with the fire
with the Badgers now before we get to
the entrance we have to talk about what
is going on over here on the right side
we have an NPC here standing just kind
of staring directly in the center of
these barrels and then as we're going by
we the player also see there's some sort
of little shimmering object here so my
guess is that that would be a start of
some sort of minor side quest maybe we
walk over and talk to this student to
get things started maybe we're going to
need the revelio charm here which was
used to reveal concealed objects
messages and visible things passages or
even hidden markings now it could also
be something to do with actually getting
the Hufflepuff door to open because we
do not see it happen in the short little
clip here however fans will know that
the barrel two from the bottom middle of
the second row needs to be tapped to the
rhythm of Helga Hufflepuff to enter and
if this is tapped incorrectly or the
wrong Barrel is tapped one of the other
Lids will burst off and Drench the
unfortunate student in vinegar so maybe
this student here is really just
contemplating which Barrel was it again
so there's a lot of things going on here
it could be a side quest it could be a
revelio thing or it could actually be
tied to the entrance itself then we see
the doors actually open and again I
Gotta Give Them credit man the
animations are just so good I don't
think it's as cool as the Ravenclaw
eagle or the Slytherin serpent but I do
love how the pieces of wood on either
side just sort of fold out of the way
and we get this nice little wooden in
entryway leading right into the common
room so now we are back in the main
common room area and immediately here on
the left you will see the fat fryer also
known as the Hufflepuff house ghost we
already know nearly headless Nick is in
the game for Gryffindor so nice to see
the fat fryer here as well and I would
definitely assume that the gray lady and
the Bloody Baron will be making an
appearance as well now as the camera
pans all the way around the room here we
also have to point out that it's pretty
clear the hufflepuffs enjoy their rugs
just as much as the Gryffindor common
room once the camera gets all the way
over to the right here we get an even
closer look at the portraits on the
right and then some sort of desk right
here but it doesn't appear to be a desk
that someone can sit and work at because
you see there's no room for the legs no
room to sit down we do have someone
sitting just beside it here and I just
love the little bowl of apples here on
the left side you know the hufflepuff's
always got to have some snacks available
then we're gonna go back into the room
with all of the little round doors and
we can see that there are actually more
than three on the bottom and that other
scene it looked like there were three
now here we can see that there are at
least four so it'll be interesting to
see once we can fully explore this room
how many doors go all the way along the
bottom here do they have one for every
year that'd be amazing if they had seven
doors on the bottom seven doors on the
top four boys and girls in each year and
then another look at the soft rugs in
this room and I have to point out I just
love the brick so much I don't think
that we have seen brick in any of the
other common rooms and I think it makes
perfect sense for Hufflepuff it's a
great choice to have here and then just
before this scene finishes we get
another look at a flu flame that has
been lit over here on the right side
with ignatia wildsmith there there's a
lot of discussion out there about these
flu flames and how they're going to work
we know they're going to be a fast
travel point but when it comes to the
one in the common room will we be able
to fast travel straight to it or perhaps
as some of you suggested on my last
video that maybe this is only an exit so
maybe the common room flu Flames are a
little bit different in that you can
only travel out using this flu flame
instead of being able to travel in I
mean honestly if you could just fast
travel in then it kind of defeats the
whole password system that they have set
up to protect people from getting into
houses that aren't their own but again
maybe it's just one of those things that
they have to kind of take Liberty with
and make it be a more approachable game
by allowing you to fast travel directly
into the common room if you don't want
to do the whole entrance thing every
time and then just before the scene Cuts
away I want to talk about these markings
on the floor here and I almost didn't
notice these but they stood out to me
because I don't believe we see them
anywhere else in the common room unless
I have missed them if I have let me know
in the comments below most of them seem
to be just kind of random patterns but
then there are a couple like this one
here and then the one just to the right
of it that almost look like they are
animals of some kind then we shift to a
scene with our character coming down the
stairs another look at the fat fryer
here on the left as well as a quidditch
portrait just behind him then we get a
shot of our character reaching the top
of some stairs getting ready to look
down in the main area of the Hufflepuff
common room and these little things over
here on the stairs I mean they just look
like eggs to me then the character
reaches the top of the stairs and gives
us an overhead shot of the room that
we've become familiar with throughout
this trailer and if you missed any of
the other common room breakdown videos
I'll put them on the screen now as
always thank you very much so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon